"You were meant to
carry his story".
>> Tucker: SCHOOL LOCK
ULTIMATELY THE BEGINNING AS
THOUSANDS OF ANTI-GUN PROTESTERS
ARE DESCENDING ON
WASHINGTON, D.C., THEY'LL DEMAND
THE GOVERNMENT RESTRICTS OUR
RIGHT TO BEAR ARMS BUT WHAT THEY
WON'T BE MARCHING FOR IS BETTER
LAW ENFORCEMENT AS THEY SHOULD
BECAUSE NICK WAS CRUISE WAS ONLY
ABLE TO CARRY OUT THAT MASSACRE
BECAUSE BOTH POLICE IGNORED
WARNINGS ABOUT HIS BEHAVIOR AND
COWARD AND FURY DURING THE
SHOOTING ITSELF.
MEANWHILE, A HIGH SCHOOL IN
MARYLAND TODAY, POTENTIAL MASS
SHOOTING WAS HALTED WHEN A
RESOURCE OFFICER CONFRONTED TO
STUDENTS.
PROFESSOR, THANKS FOR COMING ON.
I UNDERSTAND PEOPLE HAVE
DIFFERENT OPINIONS ABOUT THE
SECOND AMENDMENT, HOW FAR ITS
PROTECTIONS EXTEND, WHAT GUN
CONTROL LAWS WORK AND WHAT
DON'T, BUT YOU CAN'T LOOK AT THE
MASSACRE THAT WE COMMEMORATED
THIS WEEKEND AND COME AWAY NOT
CONCLUDING THAT THE PROBLEM WAS
THE LAWS IN PLACE WERE NOT
ENFORCED, SOMEONE WHO IS CLEARLY
A THREAT AND KNOWN TO BE A
THREAT WAS IGNORED, WAS ALLOWED
TO BUY A GUN AND THE POLICE ON
THE TEAM DID NOTHING TO STOP THE
MASSACRE, THAT'S ALL FACTUAL.
IT'S BEING IGNORED IN FAVOR OF
THE ATTACK ON THE NRA.
WHY IS THAT?
>> PERSONALLY, OF PRO
RESPONSIBLE GUN OWNERSHIP AND
PRO-GUN CONTROL.
THE PROBLEM IS WE FRAME THIS
ARGUMENT AS THOSE TWO THINGS
CAN'T COEXIST.
AS FAR AS NICHOLAS CRUZ, I THINK
SOME OF THE THINGS YOU ARE
SAYING ARE CORRECT.
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THIS NEW
SITUATION, SOMEONE WHO WAS A
GOOD KID, HAD NO PROBLEMS,
RESPECTFUL, AND HONOR STUDENT,
BUT HAD ACCESS TO A GUN.
>> Tucker: THERE ARE MILLIONS
OF STUDENTS WHO MEET THE
DESCRIPTION WHO DON'T HURT
ANYBODY.
IN THE CASE OF NICHOLAS CRUZ --
>> SHOULD MILLIONS OF YOUNG
CHILDREN --
>> THERE ARE MILLIONS IN
AMERICAN HOMES WHERE PEOPLE
SAFELY KEEP FIREARMS.
>> Tucker: KIDS HUNT IN RURAL
AMERICA AND IN SOME PLACES, THEY
BRING RIFLES TO SCHOOL DURING
DEER SEASON.
THIS IS BEEN GOING ON FOR
GENERATIONS.
THAT'S THE TRUTH OF IT.
THE POINT IS, HERE YOU HAVE
SOMEONE WITH MENTAL ILLNESS WHO
SHOULD NOT LEGALLY HAVE BEEN
ALLOWED TO BUY A GUN, BUT WAS
BECAUSE THE AUTHORITIES IGNORED
IT.
IF YOU REALLY CARE ABOUT
STOPPING SCHOOL SHOOTINGS, WHY
ARE WE IGNORING THAT?
I'M HONESTLY CONFUSED.
>> I UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING, I THINK ONE OF THE
ISSUES IS THE FACT THAT HE WAS
19 YEARS OLD AND WAS ABLE TO BUY
A PISTOL.
I THINK THAT'S A PROBLEM.
>> Tucker: AGAIN, HE WASN'T
LEGALLY ALLOWED TO BUY AND A GUN
BECAUSE HE WAS MENTALLY ILL AND
KNOWN TO BE MENTALLY ILL.
HE WAS A SUBJECT OF SCORES --
>> WE'RE NOT GOING TO DISAGREE
HERE.
>> Tucker: THIS IS AN ACTUAL
MASSACRE IN WHICH 70 PEOPLE
DIED.
NOBODY ON THE LEFT IS SAYING
ANYTHING.
THEY'RE PROTECTING THE PEOPLE
WHO FAILED BY NOT CALLING THEM
ON THEIR FAILURES.
IN FAVOR OF MAKING STATEMENTS
THAT THE NRA WHICH WAS NOT
INVOLVED.
>> WHAT THEY'RE TRYING TO DO IS
COVER ALL BASES.
I THINK WHAT THEY'RE SAYING IS
IT'S WRONG ON THE PART OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
LIKE I SAID, WITH YOUNG ROLLINS
TODAY, HE WAS NOT SUMMARY THAT
THE FBI OR LAW ENFORCEMENT COULD
HAVE PICKED UP ON.
THE NEIGHBORS HAVE SAID --
>> Tucker: IT JUST HAPPENED.
VERY QUICKLY, THIS IS THE
QUESTION I WANTED TO ASK.
IT'S A SIMPLE QUESTION.
WHAT SPECIFIC LAW ARE WE CALLING
FOR?
>> I THINK THERE'S MANY THINGS.
THEY'RE CALLING FOR A RAISE IN
THE AGE LIMIT.
WE HAVE A KID HE WAS 18 OR 19 --
>> I HAVEN'T FINISHED.
WE HAVE KIDS WHO ARE NOT MATURE
ENOUGH TO TAKE A DRINK OF
ALCOHOL, BUT WE'RE WILLING TO
GIVE THEM A DEADLY WEAPON.
>> Tucker: DO YOU REALLY
BELIEVE THAT TO BAN BUMP STOCKS
AND RAISE THE AGE TO 21, DO YOU
THINK WE WOULD END SCHOOL
SHOOTINGS?
>> I THINK WE WOULD LIMIT SOME
OF THOSE.
I BELIEVE THAT.
WHEN WE LOOK AT NICHOLAS CRUZ --
>> Tucker: HE WAS NOT ALLOWED